if you're trying to build a super truck
you're gonna need a super test and that
means a trip to the world's largest wind
tunnel truck maker Navistar has poured
five years of work into this concept big
wave it's part of the Department of
Energy super truck program an effort to
increase trucking fuel efficiency by 50
percent the results of this truck can be
used to pass on greater fuel efficiency
to our customers so reduce emissions
lower cost for transportation it's all
about cutting drag to improve efficiency
that means sleek cameras instead of
bulky side view mirrors wheel caps extra
trailer skirts even a boat tail to
reduce the trucks weight but there's
only so much Navistar can learn from
simulations so the company hauled the
truck to Mountain View California home
of the national full-scale aerodynamic
complex
to see how it handles high velocity
winds open during World War two
this facility helped develop early jet
planes and the NASA space shuttle in
1987 they added this tunnel the world's
biggest it's 80 feet high and 120 feet
wide large enough to hold a Boeing 737
this sucker has blasted a hundred mile
per hour winds at everything from
helicopters and planes to the parachute
that landed the Curiosity rover on Mars
at the beginning of each test engineers
in the control room fire up six massive
turbines each runs a twenty two thousand
five hundred horsepower motor and in
minutes this place becomes a giant
vacuum sucking air from the outside and
steering it back out the other end it
moves so much way into the air force
which now runs the facility warns local
pilots about turbulence before cranking
up to full speed no surprise things can
get a bit out of hand
for example parts can break off and go
flying down the tunnel there's a lot of
things that can go wrong so we have an
entire crew of people making sure that
we're doing this properly safely and
that everybody walks away at the end of
the day and ready to go in the mall
today's test is a bit common Navistar
Engineers study data from inside the
vehicle and monitor how this smoke flows
around the exterior they'll use the test
results to spot weak points and perfect
the aerodynamics
in the meantime the team at the wind
tunnel is already preparing for its next
giant client